Mitsy my name's Peter Richards I will be
chairing proceedings tonight standing in
for Danny Kendall who is unable to join
us if I could start by asking both
members of the committee and members of
the public to ensure their phones are
turned to silence I don't mind people
using their phones provided it doesn't
distract from the business we're
conducting here tonight but if they can
be on silent that would be a a good
start and I would also remind members of
the public that this is a meeting with
public participation it is not a public
meeting so only members of the public
that have registered to speak can speak
and you'll be called upon by me at the
appropriate time if I'll allow me to
introduce all of our officers so to my
far right is am banks from committee
services to my immediate right is Ross
chambers our solicitor and head of legal
services to my immediate left is David
Jeffries who is our planning manager he
will have something to brief a committee
with in just a moment - David's left
it's Paul Thompson and then all the way
on our far end there is Ryan O'Keefe
they are planning offices David do you
want to make your statement now thank
chair just confirm my name is David
Jeffrey I'm the planning manager for
tonight's meeting my role is to provide
impartial advice to clarify any planning
issues that arise and to assist members
decision taking I am bound by the Royal
Town Planning Institute's code of
Professional Conduct planning committee
members are not bound by advice from
offices or by their recommendations
thank you thank you David and we have
any apologies for absence please
chairman we have apologies from
councillor Kendall and for whom
councillor accomplished very kindly
substituting and councillor Adam for who
counselor Rock is substituting thank you
very much councillor Crump Castlerock
thank you for joining us members do have
a need to cloak disclosures of interests
councillor Perry good evening chair
thank you
I am the county councillor for the Wales
form Division which incorporates Hampton
Lucy reference the application number 19
forwards now
0 to 7 4 /f ul but I come to the
committee with an open mind thank you
very much in a simple a very same
application I am also the ward member
the local Ward member I've made no
comments I'm here with an open mind as
well so I will remain on the committee
for decision any other disclosures No
ok we have some minutes to confirm so
and for me to sign these a minutes for
planning committee East that was held on
the 10th of April and from planning
committee West on the 3rd of April and
the 24th of April are you happy for me
to sign those as true and accurate
because the Perry thank you counter the
bonds fabulous I'll do that after the
meeting right on to main business so
first planning application which is 19
oblique 0 0 0 5 3 oblique ful has been
withdrawn so we won't be hearing that
tonight application number 6 on your
list so application 1900 to 7 for ful I
propose we bring that forward for a
brief discussion committee we have we
have a couple of options here as you
know we're in a miserable year and
hamptonality
have liked us been through a new
election they have a full new committee
I think two members were returned
unfortunately they didn't miss the
deadline for requesting to speak it's
not it's something I imagine what
happened a few times with new members of
parish councils and possibly for new
members of this this council under
normal circumstances we would be seeking
to delegate this decision to officers so
I believe we have an option to do that
tonight
alternatively we can hear it in full
taking into consideration the comments
that have been made by both applicant
and the parish council within the report
but we won't be able to hear from the
parish council they are here I know they
are here
we won't be able to hear from them so I
open it to you as committee members to
put proposal to either delegate or to
hear it in full council bonds good to
see elections okay it's a proposal but
so I'm looking for a I'm looking I'm
looking for a proposal to either
delegate to officers which is under our
Constitution or we can hear in full now
bear in mind we won't be able to hear
from the parish council tonight we can
only take into consideration what is
within our report and we do have the
applicants registered to speak so they
will speak if we decide to hear and fold
the alternative is to delegate offices
okay Castle Rock obviously Minister TIFF
era and I think we could all understand
how that's occurred is there not a third
option to defer it so both parties can
be heard
I knew interests of fairness in another
forum we can defer but you need to have
a very strong planning reason to defer
we also are in a position where we could
have an appeal against an on
determination and it's is for you to
weigh up whether you think a there is a
strong enough reason to defer and B the
potential for an on determination they
are here to show to demonstrate the vet
that it is an administrative oversight
that they they want to ensure that we as
a committee understand that they have
objected on solid grounds and they
believe to be solid grounds but it was
an administrative error they were
prepared to speak and support their
objection but we will not be able to
bring them forward because that it would
breach our Constitution
council bans you indicated that you'd be
happy with a delegation are you
proposing that okay thank you I need a
seconder for that okay Thank You
councillor Jennings that is proposed
saying that we have a vote to please my
show of hands sound against six sorry
that was six German one chairman and
abstention one thank you so that's
passed that has been delegated to
officers okay so that leaves us with our
final application Thank You Ryan for
your attendance
that leaves us our final application
which is application 1900 four four zero
vary and north of Harrow hill cottage
inland Compton our presenting officer is
Paul Thompson
okay the application set is indicated
here by the the black dots it's the
northern edge of long Compton the foot
of Harrow Hill here we can see a
slightly larger scale the purple outline
here is the long continent Conservation
Area and the application site is this
red outline here the green dashes are
public rights-of-way and the green
circles here are tree preservation
orders and the red buildings these for
example are listed buildings none of
these features has any real impact on
the matter at hand this is an
application to vary a condition on a
2017 planning permission the condition
relates to the approved plans this
application is a retrospective attempt
to approve certain discrepancies between
the plans as approved to the building as
the
here we can see the red out light again
is the is the application site and the
blue outline is land within the same
ownership the red dashed outlines which
you might just be able to make out here
and here show the extent of the
outbuildings that were originally
present on site and have since been
demolished this is the site plan as
amended so this is what we're looking at
tonight
the footprint and the siting of the
darling itself are unchanged but there
are additional hard surfaces to the west
which is here and the South which is
here
there was a patio on the original plans
but it's now larger there is a drainage
[ __ ] channel around the foot of the
dwellings walls marked in blue this land
here outlined in blue is also in the
same ownership does not form part of the
current application site and the
eventual disposition of that land is not
a factor affecting the current decision
just as an aside there any development
on that site or a change of use of that
site would require a separate planning
permission it's outside the built-up
area boundary of long Compton and so in
terms of built development that's fairly
limited potential this slide again
compares the plans as approved at the
top and the plans as amended at the
bottom the blue outline is a dwelling
that was refused in 2016
this shows the massing and height of the
approved dwelling house in 2017 and
shows the the levels ground levels on
site and also the extent of stone walls
across the frontage the bottom as you
can see the red dashed outlines here
show the differences between the wall
which is to be reinstated you'll see in
a few slides time that it's not
there and the wall as it was so again we
have on the left the approved plans and
on the right the amended plans that
we're looking at tonight all the
differences are helpfully indicated with
red circles firstly we have the size
amount and shape of the fenestration
windows and doors they're mostly live in
the same location more or less they just
have been enlarged the original Planning
Commission did not specify materials for
these windows or add a condition which
would require details to be submitted
which means that had these changes
occurred after the dwelling had first
been occupied and they would have been
lawful the next set of alterations are
these two internal alterations this one
here is removal of a wall on the landing
to open that up and this one here is the
removal of the garage which you can see
on the original plans there and its
replacement with a fourth bedroom again
these are internal alterations so
they're not development had they
occurred after the dwelling had been
completed and occupied they would have
been lawful without any permission from
us and I should go back to this slide
and just mentioned that the there is a
wall add a Cotswold stone wall which has
been replaced here with a postal rail
fence and the retaining wall also of
Cotswold stone that wall has essentially
been relocated to the far end of this
adjoining adjoining land so the photos
this is this was taken on the site visit
for the original application
it's taken from the access of the site
there is the wall that I've mentioned
and you can see the out buildings on the
site this is the same roughly the same
location earlier this year and the wall
is gone you can see and their building
has been built this is stunning in
roughly the same location looking down
into the site just to give you an idea
of the foreground levels for reference
my feet are about level with halfway up
that window that you can see on the
right-hand side this is just looking up
Harold Hill you can see the access on
the left you see the sort of the
buildings that are on the site before
and that's just for comparison there so
just to this story just this also shows
you may have read in the report the
County highways engineer referred to an
area of land on street use for parking
that's the area of land here so just to
sum up this is a all we're looking at
here is the effect of these alterations
on on the the acceptability moment we're
not looking again at the principal at
the development any difference between
these plans that we have in front of us
and the building as it stands is a
matter for enforcement to to look into
and we have no highways objection on the
grounds of parking or traffic or any
other matter
thank you very much so if we move in
that case to our first speaker who is
councillor Blackwell from long comments
and parish council which is come forward
and welcome to the committee there is a
button at the bottom in the middle if
you press that a red light will come on
you have three minutes as soon as you
ready to start please go ahead and I'll
give you a second warning okay thank you
for evening long Compton Parish Council
we were surprised to find this its
application is a very and clearly
whether it should all have been
retrospective page two of the committee
report states the proposal seeks
retrospective planning permission to
regularize the differences between
approved and implemented versions of the
development fenestration we would ask
that all roof lights are conservation
standard and adequate provision to be
provided to all windows prevent light
spill to comply with the dark skies
policy III of the neighbourhood plan
garage there is no point in objecting to
the garage being converted to a living
space as it has been rendered useless
with the building now sitting in a very
large deep hole however this is now
reduced the parking capability whilst
adding extra living space with
potentially more vehicles and inadequate
parking added to which County highways
now appear to consider it okay for a
vehicle to reverse out of the property
onto a narrow country lane opposite of
farm gateway boundary we are assured
that the purchased agricultural land
will remain agricultural and we insist
this be the case
I must not extend the existing purchase
of the property
thereby breaching the village boundary
as defined in the neighborhood plan to
this end we would want the dry stone
wall which define the boundary of the
property and the village be reinstated
albeit with a pedestrian gate to relay
the occupiers access to the land a post
and rail fence will not suffice in
conclusion we are committed to defer
decision on this application until a
site visit has been made
to properly assess the differences
between the approved and implemented
versions of the development and take
note of the serious objections from
other parties in close proximity to the
development
thank you very much if you would remain
seated while I ask members if they have
any questions
councillor bonds weather we've got a
picture with this Wally one back
boundary have we got a map mr. chairman
are not the way that we do but I asked
officers to have a map to show whether
but the wall used to be okay it sounds
like that question has been answered
other members any other questions no in
that case counselor thank you very much
for you for your time if you get press
the button to turn off the microphone
that was very helpful okay in that case
to our next speaker is mr. Robin Hall
mr. Hall if you'd like to make your way
forward
it's the same drill if we can mister
also the red button the button in the
middle it will turn red when it's on as
soon as you're ready start speaking
we'll start the clock you have three
minutes now I'll give you a 30-second
warning Thanks thank you just really
just to express my disappointment where
we are with this application something
that new officers failed to point out
was that when this was approved in 2017
he did withdraw his development rights
on this site something that hasn't been
mentioned all the work that's been done
has been done presumably under permitted
development rights that were withdrawn
so I don't see how any of the
alterations are actually illegal the
changing levels the change in the
windows the garage has been removed the
trees have been removed the use of the
land adjoining probably going to end up
as garden changing the village boundary
it's all been done without permission if
the intent was to build 4-bedroom house
although the application was for a
two-bedroom house if the intent was to
build four-bedroom house why wasn't an
application submitted for that it just
gives out the signal that anyone can put
in any application regardless of what
you the committee or the members or the
officers support or prove you can build
what you want then come back and with
the application recommended for
permission the council will roll over
and just accept it it just puts out a
message that just build what you want it
doesn't matter because I'm sure you all
care very much about the area but that's
not the message the key comes across
thank you thank you very much members do
you have any questions for mr. Hall no
in that case thank you very much
okay to our final speaker from the
public please and if I could call on
Miss Troost Harding speaking on behalf
of the applicant good evening welcome
once again if you press the button in
the middle it will turn red and feel
free to start speaking when you're ready
you have six minutes and I'll again give
you a 30-second warning so over to you
good evening chair and members of the
committee I'm here today to represent my
parents who are unable to attend as
their way celebrating their wedding
anniversary and I'm therefore reading
this on behalf of my parents they'll be
reading it in first person I am the
applicant and thank the planning officer
for his support and I'm here to speak in
favor of the application it is a sorry
situation that we are here tonight
having to speak in favor of our
application as a parish council and
clearly persistent objectives and their
objection has brought us here tonight at
the meeting where our application was on
the past agenda the chair stated that we
didn't want it in first place we still
don't like it going to keep on objecting
which is not democratic and not fair for
the applicant who is no chance against
the pre decided outcome some members of
the parish council have voiced their
objections more than once as councilor
and as individuals and their wives which
seems unfair to have several means of
representation for example for the seven
residents objections of the parish
council and two other objections being
made from the same address I attend the
majority of parish council meetings and
I can see the pattern the predetermined
decisions not once have I seen a
councillor vote against the decision or
speak out and say what if or how about
the decisions are always unanimous there
have been many allegations and then tree
stated about us and I believe these are
personal grudges of course it is always
the voice and of course it is always the
vocal few who make their objection known
not the many who've stopped
chatted complimented or looked looked
around throughout their building process
the front wall to the west will be
rebuilt
I realize it's removal has caused
concerns for which I apologize
it had no funder foundation and had been
built in eight unpaid sections over a
few decades and had to be removed for
underground electrical supply and
removal of poles for Western power
drains and telecommunications I'd like
to state that the rule dates from 30s
and 50s not three hundred years of
alleged I don't believe coke bottles and
Woodbine cigarettes for around three
hundred years ago and many of these
objects were found within the wall we
have many people stop and look Kirtland
chats with me interested in the building
process know and expressed any
displeasure to me including the
occupiers of five of the immediate
neighboring properties all were
complimentary I'd like to read some
extracts and other officers report no
new furnace tration must be introduced
in the sensitive South elevation and the
introduction of Stainland tools and
sills is supported by neighborhood plan
and compared to the approved plans none
of the changes will affect neighbor
privacy except perhaps positively in
terms of the relocated roof lights on
the south-facing slope the following
statements by the office officer is also
very relevant the wall has not been lost
but rather relocated some 20 meters
northwards he continues to say that I
considered that the reinstated wall will
provide appropriate screening and an
adequate contribution to local character
and the relocation of the retaining
walls within the site are considered a
positive step improving privacy to the
south of the site by lowering the patio
area the steps at the northwestern
corner of the site will be obscured by
the developments and the boundary walls
and I consider it neither necessary nor
reasonable to impose condition requiring
it details of the steps to be submitted
for approval again it says the numerous
voices of the few rather than the silent
majority expressed in their opinion I
must rest again that the highways have
no objection to vehicular access nor
parking provisions on-site finally the
officer states in his report I can
identify in a way in which he's fairly
low-key and appropriate alterations
would significantly harmed the
conservation area or outstanding area of
natural beauty or have any unacceptable
impact on local a landscape character I
do hope that you mindful debated in
support of this that
and thank you for your time and
consideration and I just like to mention
in response to the objections and that
the agricultural land to the north it
should not be discussed here tonight but
is outside the application site and then
in response to the wind days and the
fenestration that the changes are minor
indeed I don't know what to change a fun
thing on many of the red circles when
days the Velux windows to the south
south are of a high position that for
navies of buildings itself and a nice
bright lights their privacy is not
compromised in terms of dark skies the
windows are black outlines have now been
fitted to all brief windows and shutters
are in production for the large gable
windows and in terms of parking we have
been unable to continue with driveway
construction and other ground works
until resolution of certain aspects and
are eager to complete the build and have
a driveway patio and landscaped areas
and not be living on a building in sight
thank you thank you thank you very much
members do we have any questions
councillor bonds just bear with me also
check through the notes
I know there the wall has been rebuilt
further up the property so it's just
been moved further along members any
other questions nope thank you very much
for your input so um we was now moved to
the wall member who has registered to
speak unfortunately she has not been
able to attend tonight so I have in
front of me a statement from her that I
will read out verbatim if I may so this
is from councillor Whaley organs
good evening committee and assemble
interest interested parties I apologize
for being unable to attend the planning
meeting to discuss at this retrospective
planning application are therefore
submit the following comments for your
serious consideration it is clear from
the number of number and seriousness of
both the objections and comments made
about this development made both on an
informal and formal basis that there is
a great deal of ambiguity about what is
going on at this site in long Compton I
believe that the opacity reflected by
the retrospective planning app playing
permission before you today does not
reflect the true scale of deviation from
the original plan Commission on many
serious matters which may include in
intentional boundary changes I therefore
fail at the decision regarding the
granting of retrospective planning
permission on this matter be deferred
until a full site visit can take place
so the scale and number of deviations
can be ascertained in detail I believe
that a deferral at this stage would
potentially save a great deal of time
for all parties concerned as it is vital
that the full facts mother's development
are ascertained before any further
consent are given if you could consider
that during your deliberations I won't
ask you for questions because I'm not
able to answer them okay so those are
our speakers our next step then is to go
to questions before our officers who
would like to start councillor Perry
Thank You chair I just wonder whether
the officers can confirm whether the
fenestrations
are
in accordance to conservation standards
that was raised by the parish council
they are not the roof lights are stand
proud of the the roof slope which
wouldn't be a conservation star roof
light that said there wasn't a condition
on the original Commission requiring
details of those roof lights to be
submitted and they weren't specified in
any detail in that application I'm gonna
follow that I'm just asked that would it
be unreasonable for us to put that on as
a condition now given it wasn't on the
original planning application members
would need to consider the harm arising
from the roof lights as it exists now if
a condition were to be put on up that
nature the existing development would be
manifestly in breach of it and it would
be a matter for enforcement to consider
whether they should enforce that
condition on that basis it would be for
members to consider how harm arises from
the roof lights as existing whether that
is harm to conservation area amenity of
the area and so on as my colleague
reflected on a moment ago it wasn't a
condition of the approval previously
granted that these should be
conservation roof lights or that they
should be to a prescribed size or
dimension or that details of those
should be shared with the local
authority in that respect the changes
before members here are to do with the
size and position of the roof lights
rather than the style in particular okay
thank you caster rock on the subject of
of the roof lights we've heard that some
comments about spill light spill and
light spill being referred to in the
neighborhood plan
we've also heard from the applicant that
they put some blinds on there I'm not
completely sure how if their blinds on
windows there could be obviously open at
9:00 so if that's been put on to prevent
light spill could that be conditioned or
is that unreasonable for that that's the
first question another question it
relates to the wall being demolished if
this is a conservation zone and the wall
has been demolished presumably
demolition is required in a conservation
area so if we approve this application
have we authorized the demolition of the
wall so again I come back to the point
of the sort of style of the windows I
think that there wasn't control over the
style and size of the roof like windows
other than that they must be developed
in accordance with the approved plans in
terms of light spill generally speaking
it isn't reasonable to impose a
condition seeking for blinds to be in
place
in habitable rooms clearly that affects
the immunity of of those rooms I think
in this circumstance where there is a
roof that has already been approved with
roof lights in it and rooms within the
building that would be lit at night
the principle if you like of having roof
lights on this roof is is largely
accepted by the council as we've
approved a scheme that has roof lights
in it previously in turning to the
comments about the demolition of the
wall yes the granted planning permission
effectively can allow for demolition
replacement and at war so long as it's
in accordance with the plans which are
approved
if that makes sense counselor bonds just
to check on this wall they say they've
realigned it so it's not where it was is
it the same size and mass book do you
know how much is it eight inches or it's
having not visited the site myself in
2017 I can't give you much of a steer on
what was there before but I can say that
it has been moved from this location
here to here and that really well
repositioned food perhaps being more
accurate the wall along the frontage
here has been realigned very slightly
but that's not sick not significantly
councilor Perry Thank You chair I mean
obviously what we're looking at is to
look at the level of harm with this
variation what I did pick up on during
the officers presentation was that if
the application or the if the main
building had been completed and was
occupied it would come under permitted
the changes would be under permitted
development rights yeah if I just have
clarification on on that in what you
actually mentioned in your presentation
that if it was fully occupied and
finished what what they've actually
proposing would not be an issue
I add on a point of fact there mr. Hall
in his presentation was entirely correct
condition 11 of the original planning
permission does remove emitted
development rights for new windows for
dormer windows and none of which we're
looking at here and for other reef
alterations which would incorporate
again new roof lights however the
internal alterations would remain lawful
if they had been conducted after the
building and been completed so I just
explained that to me again so the
internal changes would fit under that
they're not covered by this development
anyway internal changes don't require
planning permission but the roof lights
there is a removal of PD particularly
for the roof lights is that what you're
saying so these are wouldn't fall under
the mr. development but would still be
lawful they the condition I can read the
condition for the record notwithstanding
the provisions of the Town and Country
Planning general committee development
order etc no development covered by
Class A B or C of part one schedule two
to that order should be carried out
without planning permission granted by
the local planning authority and other
than the windows shown on plan the
drawing number is given no additional
windows shall be inserted in the
southern overlay elevation without
Planning Commission granted by the local
planning authority now for the most way
in fact unless somebody can correct me
here the wind the alterations that we're
looking at are not new windows in new
locations so much as they are larger all
different shaped windows in the same
location or the replacement of a window
with the door okay so it seems to me
that condition specifically says no
additional windows this is a change in
size and shape as you say so actually
it's not additional and wouldn't fall
within that condition it's perhaps a
matter of debate whether it would
constitute development or not that's
clear in my head
council answers first and then we'll
come to
the height of the building is the same
as it should be all they're really doing
it put the wrong windows here am i
simplifying the thing correct casa Dixon
on my reading with the report I gained
the impression that a garage was no
longer a garage but a bedroom served by
a window I'm assuming therefore the
garage door doesn't exist and is
replaced by a window and therefore in
addition to some of the windows not
being in accordance with the original we
have a significant change and that would
have been not available under permitted
development rights because they'd been
withdrawn but also big the states in the
situation as I say accounts that that
would be there was an opening there that
was replaced by a different type of
opening and so it wouldn't be new
fenestration in that sense and it would
be prevented by that condition
yes but the internal alteration leading
to that window would not be caster comp
just farm from my five parts council I
mentioned about the stone water being
removed that it's sort of like deed and
they did the village boundary what's the
status of the BI beef that in the area
and would this impact on it anyway this
is my concern really the the Builder
barrier boundary is defined in the
lancome to neighborhood plan which was
made in 2016
it's carries full weight and the
position of a wall relative to it would
have no bearing on them on that boundary
okay councillor Perry yeah I just wanted
to come back for a little bit of
clarification on the rib the rear
boundary I'm presuming because the other
blue area is not part of this
application that we can't because I know
the parish council made reference to the
to their concern about that particular
area becoming garden land but that is
not part of this applications hearing is
it just what confirmation for that I can
confirm that the the London blue here
highlighted sits outside of the
application boundary it is also outside
of the built-up area boundary the
landowner would need to make a separate
fall planning application for that to
change use if that is what they wanted
outside the bill to bury boundary it
would be considered to be in the open
countryside the likelihood according to
policy as it stands at the moment is
that that would be resisted that's like
this that's got nothing to do with this
application I I'm returning to cancer
the Dixons point about the conversion of
the garage so such that it can no longer
accommodate vehicles and the comments of
the county
Hansol about vehicles being obliged a
third vehicle being obliged to reverse
onto the road which seem to be
modernised my reading of this situation
which do I take it but these are not
reasonable grounds to impose any sort of
condition or reasonable grounds on on
planning harm for us to be able to to
deal with that other than what's before
us this situation we have is that the
the sweat path analysis on the plan that
you can see on the screen now shows that
two cars can be parked on the site
following the engineering works that the
applicants daughter mentioned and can
exit the site in a forward gear the
fourth bedroom according to the parking
standards currently in the process of
being adopted the fourth bedroom would
generate a third need for a third
parking space however since those
standards are yet to be adopted we can
only give them limited weight the policy
then the test then becomes whether they
comply with policy CS 25 which basically
requires sufficient parking to be
available as far as the highways
engineer is concerned if that third
space is required it can be provided on
the land visible here joining the access
without any detriment to highway safety
or traffic movement that's right
I said we've got a picture an electric
charging point I don't know where that
is but if there's a vehicle on part of
that charging point does that not
interfere with the ability to vehicles
to maneuver to come out in a forward
direction so the the e vcp is here if
you can see where I'm leaning there so
you would be able to put a cable out
from that to wherever you had your car
parked which would presumably be
parallel to the road in this location
here just to address the question more
directly the sweat path that you see
there one in pink one in blue shows that
cars can maneuver independently of the
other there's no requirement for want to
move to let the other out vice versa so
we'd expect even if one was sat they're
charging for an extended period it
wouldn't prevent the proper use of that
parking area any other questions okay
before we move to debate council
diction's raised a very very good point
about the PD rights and the removal
thereof I have my concerns over that and
I've been discussing with our solicitor
we're just going to take a five minute
break while we get full legal eyes on
the condition and how it impacts this
before we come back to that debate so if
that's right we're going to take five
minutes
okay members where we are back so sorry
about that
we just wanted clarity on I wanted
particularly clarity on this that the
whole PD issue and what we're what
specifically we're looking at so to be
clear the there is a removal of PD
rights from the original planning
application however we are obviously
looking at this application on its
merits what we need to be considering is
they're planning harm by virtue of the
change in positioning size and shape of
Windows and the addition of a window
that would replace the garage of what
would otherwise would be a garage door
so it's about the planning harm not
whether or not there is it is or isn't
PD right so just wanted to make that
clear is everyone happy everyone
understand good so not to debate who
would like to pipe in first councilor
Perry thank you chair
I remember this application really quite
well having sat on this when it first
came through about two or three years
ago and I know the site has been very
controversial on a local level but
having looked at all I mean obviously
the proposal to change the garage into a
bedroom we do have a situation where the
parking new policy is currently go it is
easing at a draft stage and even if the
the occupants used their garage not to
keep a car in that could well have been
three cars parked there anyway plus
there is room just outside the property
for parking that if that keeps it off
the highway in a nutshell looking at it
whilst I understand and appreciate the
parish councils concerns I can see no
material planning reason to refuse this
application and therefore I will be
voting in
port of the officers recommendation just
won't clear is that proposal to grant or
is that just an expression of your no
I'm quite happy to propose to grant in
favor of grant the applicants the rock
Thank You chairman I'm somewhat
uncomfortable with the development
appears to have proceeded with with act
plumbing approval and I can see the
concern that's been expressed by the
local community and parish council I'm
also minded to hear what the ward
members said about the need for site
visit for us to fully understand what's
gone on but on the other hand the
officers seem to produce quite
comprehensive plans and elevations
showing us the changes so I think that's
quite clear showing us what has taken
place but I think council of Perry Perry
has X voiced what our difficulty in the
planning harm has arisen from that it's
quite difficult for us to refuse that
these changes notwithstanding what I've
just said about how it's all come about
so I don't think I'm in a position to
second it but I can say entirely what
she's saying so I'm uncomfortable in
approving it but I can't find a reason
not to understand but again I struggled
to see the harm on it
so I'd like to thank you councilor Crum
sorry you indicated I apologize
councillor chromecast the band's please
I'm sorry
this is remember committee committee
there was talk of the windows that there
was concern as you write shame that if
you like them that it properly
highways bedrooms County Council there's
nothing we can do if they say he's okay
we stuck so as far as I'm concerned
reluctantly but be happy - Thank You
councillor Crump
I was preferred age before beauty so I
didn't mind standard Potter that's the
balance he beats you on both count and
definitely I could read you is that yeah
just one understanding of the conditions
and again it's probably number nine
service runs is that to do with the
utilities I've didn't quite I've seen
that before I just wonder what that
means on the condition number nine
so if we're gonna get through those so
I'd like to understand what the
conditions are and it might be even
slightly dance but
counselor I suspect that's an oversight
on the original proposals there were a
number of trees to be retained and the
service runs we usually seek for the
protection of those trees to ensure that
protection areas don't get harmed in
this instance it's clear from the photos
and from the officer's comments that the
trees have actually gone now anyway so
that condition may prove unnecessary
Council Rock given the clarification we
just had about permitted development
rights or see removal of permitted
develop Meister's proposed on here is
for the side and rear extension roof
alterations and windows in the southern
elevation it's a question probably for
the office isn't for counselor poll
that's proposed it could we not remove
all permitted development rights for
this building in view of the history in
question would that be reasonable and
would the proposer accept it because we
seem to have had some loss of control
over this site is that reasonable and
would it be acceptable no unfortunately
we shouldn't remove PD rights except in
exceptional circumstances and with just
cause we have in this case reasons to
protect the immunity of the neighbor to
the south and that's why those
particular set of conditions were
proposed certainly we should not
consider for a moment removing PD rights
as a punitive measure okay I think that
answers that so unless there's any
further debate or contribution we have a
proposer from councillor perixx been
seconded by Councillor Jennings subject
to the removal of condition 9
could I please have a [ __ ] could I
please have a show of hands for all
those in favor of granting along those
lines disgusting can I just clarify on
the update sheet where it talks about
the red line boundary clarification okay
apologies councillors we're gonna have
to do that again so the recommendation
is to grant with a removal of condition
9 and subject to the amended
recommendation in the update sheet have
you all had a chance to read your
updates use okay so that's the
recommendation can we please have
another show of hands and for those in
favor of that recommendation he
anonymous chairman in that case that has
been passed and granted thank you very
much our next order of business is to
decide on the timings of our meetings
are you all happy to continue at quarter
past 6:00 we would like it moving
councillor Barnes you prefer six sorry
chair I'm not able to leave Kyneton
until half-past five on a Wednesday
subject to I'm happy for it to be six
but I might not turn up until ten past
six
okay it's anyone else on the other view
I mean frankly I'm quite happy with
quarter past six I know Danny obviously
Danny chairs this meeting
frankly 6:00 or 6:15 doesn't make any
difference to me but I know Danny chairs
normally I think probably be remiss of
me to make a decision without him here
cause he has school commitments as well
I think perhaps we defer the sides into
the next one will have 6:15 the next one
and then we'll get Danny's input as well
then that makes more sense doesn't it
everyone happy with that okay and we
have no further urgent business so in
that case the meeting is closed thank
you very much